je vous le disais au début de cette
édition francis huster comédien écrivain
était dans les yvelines samedi journée
marathon pour lui avec dédicaces dans
l'après midi à la librairie de montigny
le bretonneux avant de partir pour bois
d'arcy pour une représentation de brooks
est une pièce à succès où il compte pas
moins de dix huit personnages dans une
ambiance très sombre du new york mafieux
des années 60 son interview avec julie
rocha soares sous le charme
forcément c'est tout de suite bonjour
francis huster vous êtes en dédicace au
pavé du canal pour quelques heures
car vous êtes comédiens réalisateurs
mais aussi écrivain
on connaît lettre aux femmes et à
l'amour est aussi et dior créa la femme
dernièrement vous avez publié albert
camus un combat pour la gloire
comment a évolué l'idée de ce livre vous
êtes carrément dans la peau d'albert
camus
en fait quand j'ai commencé les
premières représentations de la teste
il ya plus de vingt ans jean louis
barrault m'a demandé d'écrire après
chaque représentation de trois pages sur
sur camus est là au bout d 963
représentation donc ça fait tu vois pas
mal de page g j'ai sorti toutes les
pages et un jeune éditeur le passeur m'a
demandé pour le centenaire de came de
publier quelque chose
et finalement j'ai préféré écrire ce
roman avec avec l'idée la reconnaissance
même que ce soit calmes et lui-même qui
parle parce que
en fait quand albert camus avait reçu
son prix nobel à stockholm le plus jeune
prix nobel de littérature français et là
il a donné une petite rencontre
l'université d'uppsala avec des
étudiants et là il a été agressé par un
étudiant algérien et un propos
évidemment du terrorisme en algérie du
fln de cette guerre d'algérie et
curieusement camus lui a répondu parce
qu'il était assez choqué par
l'intervention de cet étudiant
évidemment entre le les bombes dans un
tramway qui pouvaient tuer sa mère et sa
mère il préférait sa mère alors
il avait parfaitement raison de répondre
évidemment cette phrase mais elle a été
manipulée détourné par
l'intelligentsia de saint germain et des
bons esprits de l'époque on trahit camus
qu'il jalouse est et la vie de gamme est
devenue un enfer
à partir de ce moment là alors j'ai
essayé dans ce livre de répondre comme
il aurait pu répondre s'ils en avaient
eu le temps à sept étudiants algériens
et de traiter tous les problèmes
cruciaux dans l'oeuvre de camus son
regard sur dieu son regard sur l'algérie
sont revient sur le terrorisme son
regard sur la france métropolitaine
autant de thèmes qui sont aujourd'hui
d'actualité en fait qu'ils sont mais
incroyablement pour son santé
injustement d'une actualité
qui en plus est une actualité qui donne
à réfléchir et qui nous oblige à poser
des questions à la jeunesse et à lui
demandé elle-même d'y répondre
alors je m'attendais pas du tout aux
succès incroyable de ce livre mais ce
succès je ne partage évidemment
d'arrêter jeux d'éditeurs le passeur
puis avec jean louis barrault qui m'a
forcé à écrire mais je pense que son
succès montrent au moins des canuts dans
le monde entier l'auteur français le
plus le plus le plus admiré mais surtout
le plus représentatif de la france et
vous quand vous rencontrez votre public
comme aujourd'hui au pad et du canal
qu'attendez-vous de de cet échange avec
vos lecteurs des des questions et donc
des réponses des deux côtés vu l'heure
et du mien sûr
sur cette espèce de paralysie de manque
de courage de tant de justement de
d'artistes vis-à-vis de ces questions de
ces questions là on vient encore de bon
d'être complètement foudroyé par tout ce
qui se passe dans le monde et c'est pas
fini on sait que c'est pas fini
on n'est pas dans une guerre mondiale
mais on est dans une guerre morale et et
elle fait autant de victimes que l'autre
dans le sens où de plus en plus y'a des
gens qui sont désespérés
vous parliez tout à l'heure de théâtre
on en vient puisque vous allez jouer
bronx juste après ce rendez-vous à
montigny-le-bretonneux
ça se passera du côté de bois d'arcy
pour une immersion dans les années 60
vous aller camper les 18 personnages de
la pièce comment vous gérez ça
un musicien qui interpréterait dans un
concert schumann schubert chopin brahms
layton s'est déclenché à des personnages
de l'histoire est un instrument
différent et plus de travail
toutes les répliques du même personnage
même si elles sont éparpillées seul tu
vois tu construis chaque réplique je
pense et chaque mouvement et après tu
fais le
le sandwich de tout quoi c'est comme un
moment tu es toi-même douleur castres
c'est une pièce qui est très apprécié
autant par les critiques que le grand
public vous prenez toujours autant de
plaisir à chaque représentation
non c'est pas du plaisir c'est comme si
tu te jeter dans le vide et le plaisir
il n'est en fait après la représentation
j'ai pas dans cette pièce d'être heureux
ou ou angoissé ou de me laisser aller
c'est vraiment c'est grande expliqué
c'est comme ça me fait tout à fait
penser pour biathlon c'est à dire tu
cours tu prends la carabine qui tirent
et tu peux pas te déconcentrer mais mm
et je pense que voilà c'est pas du foot
hein tu peux pas faire n'importe quoi
merci beaucoup francis huster de nous
avoir accordé ce sens nous allons vous
laisser à votre séance de dédicaces et
ensuite je rappelle que vous serez à
bois d'arcy pour interpréter les 18
personnages de bronx de cette suite se
poursuit à présent en plateau à
guyancourt où le retrouve wilfried rifi